programming throwdown episode 66 code reviews take it away jason. Hey, everyone. This is our double for this month because of my illness last month. And one thing I did last month, even though I was quite sick, I was able to assemble a 3D printer, which was actually super, super fun. I went on GearBest, which is some Chinese distributor, and I ordered a 3d printer kit it was literally just bags of screws and wires and and rods and and uh like this thing that had been cut out of acrylic like a bunch of little acrylic pieces and some stepper motors that you could have got just right off the shelf at Fry's or something. But, you know, it came with the whole kit.
Programming Throwdown 第66期，代码审查。Jason，开始吧。大家好。这是我们这个月的双倍节目，因为我上个月生病了。上个月我做了一件事，尽管病得很重，但我还是组装了一台3D打印机，这其实超级超级有趣。我上了GearBest，那是一家中国分销商，我订购了一个3D打印机套件，里面真的就是一袋袋螺丝、电线、杆子，还有一些用亚克力切割出来的零件，以及一些本可以在Fry's之类的店里直接买到的步进电机。但是，你知道，它是一个完整的套件。
And it was very daunting. I mean, the thing that scared me the most was at one point I pulled out of the box like a 120-volt, like, plug that would plug into the wall. And the other end was just three bare wires. Don't stick them to your tongue. Yeah, and I just thought, I mean, I'm not one of the people that, like, put paper clips in the sockets when I was younger or something. And so that whole, like, everything related to, like, electrical work, I just have no familiarity with. But I just dove in. I knew that there were going to be a lot of good resources.
这非常令人望而生畏。我的意思是，最让我害怕的是，有一次我从盒子里拿出了一个120伏的插头，就是那种插墙上的插头。而另一端只是三根裸露的电线。别把它们塞进嘴里。是的，我当时就想，我可不是那种小时候会往插座里塞回形针之类的人。所以，关于电气工作的一切，我完全不熟悉。但我还是硬着头皮上了。我知道会有很多好的资源。
And there are just an incredible amount of resources on how to do it. There's tons of videos from different angles, different people doing it. And I built it and it actually worked. It was a little bit scary. The first time I turned it on, smoke started pouring out. Oh, no. And basically, I had some of the copper strands of the 120 volt had like touched each other and completed a circuit and like melted part of the thing. But it was okay. The part it melted wasn't a big deal. That doesn't sound okay. Yeah, it was super scary. I was pretty sure I destroyed it. I got extremely lucky.
关于怎么做，有极其丰富的资源。有大量来自不同角度、不同人操作的视频。我把它组装好了，而且它真的能用。这有点吓人。我第一次打开它时，开始冒烟。哦，不。基本上，我把120伏电线的一些铜丝弄得互相接触了，形成了短路，还熔化了部分零件。但没关系。熔化的部分不是什么大问题。听起来不太妙。是的，超级吓人。我当时很确定我把它毁了。我运气极好。
Part of it, too, is as soon as I saw a bit of smoke, I unplugged it. And, yeah, so that was the first issue. The second issue was the way it works, if you've ever seen a 3D printer, you have two stepper motors, and you have these two cables that make one makes the platform go towards you and away from you and one makes the printer head go to the left and to the right but the part that makes the printer head go up and down that needs to be very very accurate and so you can't have just a plastic cable for that also you know gravity is constantly putting tension on it. So for that, they have these two metal rods that are threaded, kind of like a screw, but, you know, you're not screwing it into anything. It's just two cylinders that have a thread. And they plug into two stepper motors, and they both turn kind of in sync.
部分原因也是，我一看到冒烟就拔掉了电源。是的，那是第一个问题。第二个问题是它的工作方式，如果你见过3D打印机，你有两个步进电机，还有两条电缆，一条让平台向你靠近或远离，另一条让打印头左右移动，但让打印头上下移动的部分需要非常非常精确，所以你不能只用塑料电缆，而且你知道重力一直在给它施加张力。所以为此，他们用了两根带螺纹的金属杆，有点像螺丝，但你不是把它拧进什么东西里。它们只是两个有螺纹的圆柱体。它们插在两个步进电机上，并且它们同步转动。
And so the idea is when you turn both of these screws together it kind of makes this whole kind of platform rise up and when you turn them the other way it makes them makes it rise down um and i guess those rods needed some wd-40 or some grease or something and so i didn't do that um and uh you know like there's just like the friction was causing everything to get messed up. It wasn't, you know, the left and the right side weren't rising up the same. Um, so there's basically long story short, there were several times where I felt like I was out the $220 and I felt like it was just, uh, like, you know, I tried it, it's
所以思路是，当你同时转动这两个螺丝时，整个平台就会上升，当你反向转动时，它就会下降。我想那些杆子需要一些WD-40或润滑油之类的东西，但我没做。你知道，摩擦力导致一切都乱套了。左边和右边上升得不一致。总之，长话短说，有几次我觉得我那220美元打水漂了，我觉得我试过了，它
ruined, you know, whatever, you know, I, I kind of like, I felt kind of bad about it cause I wasted the money. Um, uh, but then in the end I finally got it to work it was just super super satisfying so what have you been making yeah so I printed a couple of things just to make uh just like some functional things um like I printed something to hold my watch um like on the dresser and things like that I also I had this crazy idea that I've had for a while and I finally got to implement it. I went on Thingiverse and I found models of lions and bears and other animals.
毁了，随便吧，我对自己感到有点难过，因为我浪费了钱。但最后我终于让它工作了，这真的超级超级有成就感。那你做了什么？是的，我打印了一些东西，只是为了做一些实用的东西。比如我打印了一个放在梳妆台上的手表架之类的。我还一直有个疯狂的想法，终于实现了。我上了Thingiverse，找到了狮子、熊和其他动物的模型。
And at first I 3D printed them and my son got to play with them and he thought it was super cool. And then I actually went in Blender, which is a 3D editing software, and I sort of detached the head. I decapitated all of these animals. And then I made the head screw and the body like a thread. And so you can actually screw off the lion head and screw it onto a bear body.
起初我把它们3D打印出来，我儿子玩得很开心，他觉得超级酷。然后我进入了Blender，这是一款3D编辑软件，我把它们的头拆了下来。我把所有这些动物都斩首了。然后我把头部做成螺丝，身体做成螺纹。所以你实际上可以把狮子头拧下来，拧到熊的身体上。
I did it kind of haphazardly. So when you screw the head on, it doesn't screw on straight. So all the animals look like they're kind of turning their head, like they're all looking over their shoulder. But it's still really fun. And my son and I, we got a huge kick out of it. That's pretty funny. Yeah, it was great. I highly recommend doing it, especially if you're like in high school or college or if you don't have a lot of experience with electrical stuff. This is a great way to get started. It was something that actually worked, which is for me and mechanical things, that was a rarity.
我做得有点随意。所以当你把头拧上去时，它拧得不正。所以所有的动物看起来都像是在转头，好像都在回头看。但这仍然非常有趣。我和我儿子从中得到了巨大的乐趣。那太搞笑了。是的，太棒了。我强烈推荐大家尝试，特别是如果你还在上高中或大学，或者如果你对电气方面没有太多经验。这是一个很好的入门方式。它真的能用，这对我这种对机械一窍不通的人来说，简直是奇迹。
Well, except for that part where you almost burned your house down. That's true. Yeah, be really careful of AC mains voltage out of your wall. It's no joke. Yeah, yeah, that's true. I mean, I was pretty sure that I was going to destroy something like fundamental in my house, and I was pretty close to doing that. All right.
嗯，除了你差点把房子烧掉的那部分。那是真的。是的，一定要非常小心墙上的交流电。那可不是开玩笑的。是的，是的，那是真的。我的意思是，我当时很确定我会毁掉房子里的什么根本性的东西，而且我离那一步非常近。好了。
Don't do this without supervision. If you're in high school or something, have your dad help you or your mom help you or have a friend over, someone who could put it out with a fire exting high school or something. Have your dad help you or your mom help you or have a friend over, someone who could put it out with a fire extinguisher or something. Words of endorsement from Jason. All right, well, time for the news. My first link is the Competitive Programmers Handbook. This is a PDF compiled by someone named Antti,
没有监督千万别这么做。如果你还在上高中什么的，让你爸爸妈妈帮你，或者找个朋友过来，找个能用灭火器灭火的人。Jason的背书。好了，现在是新闻时间。我的第一个链接是《竞赛编程手册》。这是一份由Antti编写的PDF，
or yeah, I guess Antti, and I won't attempt the last name who compiled a whole bunch of tips and tricks and algorithms for the kinds of things you would need to be able to do if you wanted to do competitive programming now you may say well competitive programming is starting a company and competing against all the other people starting a company in order to do better but competitive programming i think in this context, refers to programming competitions where a bunch of programmers gather together
或者说，我想是Antti，我不会尝试读他的姓氏，他汇编了一大堆技巧和算法，如果你想参加竞赛编程，你需要掌握这些。现在你可能会说，竞赛编程就是创办一家公司，并与所有其他创办公司的人竞争以做得更好，但我认为在这种语境下，竞赛编程指的是编程竞赛，一群程序员聚在一起，
and get assigned puzzles and problems and a time limit in which to solve them. And the sort of fastest to be able to solve, roughly, to solve the problems is the winner. And there's a sort of points, sometimes based on the difficulty of the problems, the exact structure of the competition can vary. But sometimes I think I did a couple of these when I did my computer science stuff in high
被分配到谜题和问题，并在限定时间内解决它们。大致上，最快解决问题的人就是赢家。有时会有基于问题难度的积分，竞赛的具体结构可能会有所不同。但我记得我在高中学计算机科学时参加过几次。
school. I think like my senior year maybe, but I think most people get experience with this in college. The ACM, the Association for Computing Machinery runs a really big programming competition each year. Yeah, I mean, the thing to keep in mind is that, like, there's sort of this, like, family of people who compete and then grow up and, like, grow older and become judges and then become problem writers. And so, you know, it means that there's like a specific niche of computer science that's going to cover like 90% of the problems that you see in competitive programming. And so even if you might be a super strong CS student, but you also have to study the competitive programming world
我想可能是高三的时候，但我认为大多数人是在大学里获得这种经验的。ACM（计算机协会）每年都会举办一场非常大的编程竞赛。是的，我的意思是，要记住的是，有一群人参加比赛，然后长大，变老，成为评委，然后成为出题人。所以，这意味着计算机科学中有一个特定的细分领域，涵盖了你在竞赛编程中看到的90%的问题。所以即使你可能是一个非常强的CS学生，你也必须研究竞赛编程的世界，
because it dives really deep into a handful of areas and doesn't cover other ones so right so and sometimes the the problems can be quite tricky the sort of most obvious solution will definitely not work and you need to understand sort of why it won't work and figure out what they what the trick is to it and in that way it becomes a puzzle puzzle. Yeah, yeah, absolutely. Yeah, I also, I did a bunch of these programming competitions in college. I think it's great. It's a great experience. But yeah, as I said, there's sort of this hidden like gnosis around it. And so it's really important to study.
因为它深入研究了少数几个领域，而没有涵盖其他领域。所以，有时问题可能非常棘手，最明显的解决方案肯定行不通，你需要理解为什么它行不通，并找出其中的诀窍，这样它就变成了一个谜题。是的，绝对是。是的，我在大学里也参加过很多这样的编程竞赛。我觉得这很棒。这是一种很棒的体验。但正如我所说，围绕它有一种隐藏的“灵知”。所以研究它真的很重要。
And this is actually a great resource because it really covers it in a lot of detail. And it's a great way to kind of get familiar. And a lot of the interview questions at companies, you know, kind of are modeled after competitive programming assignments because mostly because of the time limit. You know, like you have maybe an hour to solve a problem in a competitive situation, and you have an hour or even half an hour to solve a problem in an interview. And so they kind of end up converging a little bit there. So this would also help, you know, your interview skills. Yeah. And I think also just becoming comfortable with a lot of the algorithms that are necessary for the programming competitions are really helpful for the interviews as well.
这实际上是一个很好的资源，因为它非常详细地涵盖了这些内容。这是一个熟悉这些知识的好方法。而且很多公司的面试题，你知道，都是模仿竞赛编程任务的，主要是因为时间限制。你知道，在竞赛中你可能有一个小时来解决一个问题，而在面试中你有一个小时甚至半小时来解决一个问题。所以它们最终有点趋同了。所以这也将有助于你的面试技巧。是的。而且我认为，熟悉编程竞赛所需的许多算法对面试也真的很有帮助。
Yeah. Yeah, totally. Like for the reasons you said, the kind of depth you get into is about the same between the two because you just don't have much time to kind of write well architected code per se. It's mostly about sort of getting to the, coding the algorithm. But I will say most of the things in this book,
是的，完全正确。就像你说的，两者涉及的深度差不多，因为你没有太多时间去编写架构良好的代码。这主要是关于编写算法。但我得说，这本书里的大部分内容，
sort of especially the later half, are things like it would be awesome to understand and to do well in programming competitions are probably needed, but you would be unlikely to encounter these on a programming interview unless it was a really tough interviewer. Yeah, yeah, exactly.
尤其是后半部分，虽然理解它们并在编程竞赛中表现出色很棒，可能也是需要的，但除非遇到非常苛刻的面试官，否则你不太可能在编程面试中遇到这些。是的，没错。
I mean, a lot of, I would actually be surprised to even find really any dynamic programming and things like that in an interview. But yeah, I mean mean these are like super advanced things but definitely a great resource and if you're interested in or are currently doing programming competitions check it out also we do recommend um oh i forget the name of the other one but top coder is a website that has uh programming competitions and there's also and uh hacker rank is another one and and so those are also good resources to gain practice apply the knowledge knowledge you learned from this book, that kind of stuff, but also to prepare for programming interviews.
我的意思是，我甚至会惊讶于在面试中发现任何动态规划之类的问题。但是的，这些都是超级高级的东西，但绝对是一个很好的资源，如果你感兴趣或正在参加编程竞赛，可以看看。此外，我们还推荐……哦，我忘了另一个的名字，但TopCoder是一个有编程竞赛的网站，还有HackerRank也是一个，所以这些也是获得练习、应用你从这本书中学到的知识的好资源，同时也可以为编程面试做准备。
We get that question a lot from listeners. Yeah, actually, I helped someone about a month or two ago. And he asked me for help interviewing at a company I used to work at. And I told him, I said, let's just, you know, open up HackerRank and start solving problems. And I still think that's the best way to go about it. And if you don't have a lot of experience with competitive programming, then chances are, even if you're really good at CS, you're going to have a hard time with something like HackerRank, which is kind of the point. Like, it's good to see, you know, what sort of knowledge gaps there are and and there's
我们经常从听众那里收到这个问题。是的，实际上，一两个月前我帮了一个人。他让我帮他准备一家我以前工作过的公司的面试。我告诉他，我说，我们就打开HackerRank开始解决问题吧。我仍然认为这是最好的方法。如果你没有太多竞赛编程的经验，那么即使你CS学得很好，你在HackerRank这样的平台上也会遇到困难，这正是重点。看到自己有哪些知识缺口是很好的，而且
great documentation most of the these sites give you the answer along with an editorial and things like that so cool so I'm going to talk about C++ 17 and so I'll give a link to it a lot of new features a lot of cool stuff coming out it's amazing because I remember C++11 being just super, super delayed and having to rely heavily on boost. Like if you wanted even just threading, you had to use boost. And I think C++11 was originally supposed to be C++08, if I remember correctly. We could probably find out from our old episode. It took till 11 to get it out the door.
这些网站有很好的文档，会给你答案以及社论之类的东西。酷，所以我要谈谈C++ 17，我会给出一个链接，有很多新特性，很多很酷的东西出来了。这很神奇，因为我记得C++11被推迟得非常非常严重，不得不严重依赖Boost。比如如果你想要线程，你必须使用Boost。而且我认为C++11最初应该是C++08，如果我没记错的话。我们可能可以从旧节目中查到。直到11年才发布。
But now here we are with a 14 and a 17. And it's actually almost, you know, getting to the point where unless you're really heavy in a C++, you can start to lose track of the latest features. But yeah, there's some really cool stuff here. And we've provided a link so you can kind of check it out, like the latest and the greatest C++ stuff.
但现在我们有了14和17。实际上，除非你非常深入地使用C++，否则你几乎开始跟不上最新的特性了。但确实有一些非常酷的东西。我们提供了链接，你可以查看一下，了解最新最棒的C++内容。
I feel like we should enter into a segment where we discuss our favorite feature from the new... No, I'm just kidding. I mean, the one I use the most, I mean, this is covering all of the extensions, is the totally... I totally forgot. I think it's called the range operator.
我觉得我们应该进入一个环节，讨论我们最喜欢的新特性……不，我开玩笑的。我的意思是，我用得最多的，涵盖了所有扩展，是那个……我完全忘了。我想它叫范围操作符。
Basically, it's where you do like- List comprehension? Is that what it is? It's where you do like four X colon vector and then it saves you from having to write the whole for loop. I call it list comprehension, but I don't know if that's the right term.
基本上，就是你做那种……列表推导式？是那个吗？就是你做那种“for X in vector”，它省去了你写整个for循环的麻烦。我称之为列表推导式，但我不知道这是否是正确的术语。
Yeah, there's a bunch. I know it's called that in other languages. Yeah, that and the threading. Like going from boost threading to just a C++ threading is literally just changing. It's a regex, right? But I had a bunch of code and still have now. I'm producing a bunch of code that uses threads.
是的，有很多。我知道在其他语言中它叫这个。是的，那个和线程。从Boost线程转到C++原生线程，简直就是改一下。它是一个正则表达式，对吧？但我有很多代码，现在还有。我正在编写大量使用线程的代码。
And it's good that that's just baked into the language because it's so important. The other thing from C++17 that's nice is they're continuing to support sort of extra features in the const expressions. So if you write a lot of const expressions, which can be compiled time evaluated, before it was very strict what could be in them.
语言内置这个功能很好，因为它太重要了。C++17中另一个不错的地方是，他们继续支持const表达式中的额外特性。所以如果你写了很多const表达式，它们可以在编译时求值，以前对它们能包含什么非常严格。
And now there's increasing things that are added to the list of what can be in them, which is good. Cool. Yeah, doing more like type inferencing. So my next news article is called Simple Chess AI. This is an article that was posted on, I guess, somebody's Medium platform, Free Code Camp.
现在，可以包含的内容列表在不断增加，这很好。酷。是的，做更多类型推断。所以我的下一篇新闻文章叫《简单的国际象棋AI》。这是一篇发布在，我想是某人的Medium平台，Free Code Camp上的文章。
Anyways, we'll have a link in the show notes. And I came across this, but it was really interesting because a lot of people, well, you know, of course, artificial intelligence is in the news a lot. And it means lots of different things to lots of different people. So I don't think there's any neural networks or there are no neural networks in this example. and have it already set up for you to kind of plug and play your sort of move evaluator, the opposing player, the computer player. And I thought it was really cool because I've always, you know, thought to myself,
总之，我们会在节目笔记中放一个链接。我偶然发现了这个，因为它非常有趣，因为很多人，嗯，你知道，当然，人工智能经常出现在新闻中。它对不同的人意味着很多不同的事情。所以我不认为这里有任何神经网络，或者这个例子中没有神经网络。并且已经为你设置好了，让你直接插入你的移动评估器，对手，电脑玩家。我觉得这很酷，因为我一直，你知道，心想，
like, oh, I should make a, you know, chess bot or something that plays chess. But then it's always like the setting up a representation for the board and having a visualizer. It's a lot of work to get to the thing you're trying to do. And so I thought this was a particularly compact setup. I probably could have gone and found, you know, something at some point if I had been serious about it. But it comes along with the tutorial where they take you first amount, you know,
哦，我应该做一个国际象棋机器人之类的东西。但总是涉及到设置棋盘表示和可视化。要达到你想要的目标需要做很多工作。所以我认为这是一个特别紧凑的设置。如果我认真对待的话，我可能早就去找到什么东西了。但它附带了一个教程，他们带你先了解，你知道，
simply being able to make valid moves, then being able to, you know, talk about what the tree of possible moves would look like and how to evaluate that. And then how to prune that tree so that you can go farther down the tree which means in this case farther down the tree is further into the future of potential moves and that way the more you can trim as these paths aren't good then the farther down you can go the farther in the future can look and the more sort of
简单地能够进行有效移动，然后能够，你知道，谈论可能的移动树看起来是什么样的，以及如何评估它。然后是如何修剪那棵树，这样你就可以在树中走得更远，这意味着在这种情况下，在树中走得更远就是更深入地预测潜在的移动，这样你修剪掉的坏路径越多，你就能走得越远，看得越远，你的引擎就越具有预测性，能够比单纯的战术更具战略性。然后，你知道，如何为棋子的相对价值设定启发式算法？或者不同的棋子根据它们在棋盘上的位置重要性不同又该如何？以及如何编码？它实际上涵盖了很多内容。
predictive your engine becomes and being able to be a little more strategic than just tactical. And then, you know, sort of how do you have heuristics for the relative point values of the pieces? Or what about different pieces are more or less important depending on where they are on the board? And how do you sort of encode that? It goes for a lot of it, actually.
我的意思是，我不是一个伟大的国际象棋棋手，所以我很确定最终的AI可能很容易就能打败我。但我认为这是一个关于如何进行游戏AI开发的非常有趣的介绍。是的，完全正确。我的意思是，即使是一个玩家，像这样带有八步预判的简单启发式算法也会造就一个专家玩家，
I mean, I'm not a great chess player, so I'm pretty sure that AI that ends up by the end could probably beat me pretty handily. But I thought this was a very kind of interesting introduction on how to do sort of game AI. Yeah, totally. I mean, even just a player, like a simple heuristic like this with an eight-move look ahead will make an expert player
它会打败几乎所有非竞赛玩家。是的，国际象棋很难，是的，这是一款很难玩的游戏，但围棋更难，所以没错，我想我们真的应该提高门槛，编写简单的围棋AI，那很难做到。嗯，关于国际象棋的是，你可以，你知道，即使是预判八步或六步，你也可以在考虑修剪的情况下穷尽所有可能的动作。但对于围棋，我的意思是，你知道，在每一个棋盘状态下，你都有数百种动作。分支因子要高得多。是的，完全正确。好了，我们会把它放在节目笔记里，如果听起来有趣的话，去看看吧。是的，这看起来太棒了，正如Patrick所说，一步一步来，所以
that would beat almost everyone who's not a competitive player. Yeah, chess is hard yeah just a hard game to play but go is harder so that's right i guess we should really be upping the limit here in writing simple go ais that's that's hard to do um yeah the thing about chess is you can you know even eight moves ahead or six moves ahead you can exhaust all the possible actions with this pruning in mind um but with go i mean you know at every board state you have hundreds of actions yeah the branching factor is much higher yeah exactly right all right so we'll put that in the show notes so i'd check it out if it sounds interesting yeah this looks awesome i mean it's as as patrick said step by step so so there's
没有什么能阻止你自己编写这个代码，只要跟着这个教程，并且对Python或C++之类的东西有一些了解。我知道人们做的另一个经典例子是制作最差的国际象棋AI，也就是制作一个尽可能快输掉的AI。哦，真的吗？你看到那个“最差守望先锋玩家”的文章了吗？没有。所以基本上，我的意思是，这有点跑题了，但守望先锋有一个公式，可能是Elo或什么的变体，来决定人们的排名。但它是一个公式，并不是说前10个人，前10%的人是第一名，以此类推，对吧？不是那样的。所以有最差的，我想最差的排名
there's nothing stopping you from uh from from coding this up yourself um and reading just by following this tutorial and having some understanding of like a python or c++ or something like that i know another classic example people do are make the worst possible chess ai so make an ai that loses as fast as possible oh really did you see the uh worst overwatch player article no so basically i mean it's a little bit of a tangent but uh um overwatch had a formula it's probably some variant of elo or something to to decide people's rank um but it's a it's a formula it's's not like the top 10 people, top 10% of people are rank one, so on and so forth, right? It's not like that. And so there's the worst, I think the worst rank
是第一名。所以我想1是最低的。有一个人，他把达到第一名作为他的个人使命。人们认为这甚至是不可能的。他基本上，你知道，他实际上走过了……起初他和相当有竞争力的人一起玩，因为我猜最初他真的很强，人们相当成熟和友善，你知道，他输掉了所有这些比赛。然后他到了中间，当他变得比平均水平差一点时，人们变成了喷子。所以基本上，所有的喷子都是那些比平均水平稍微差一点的人，那是大多数喷子所在的地方。然后当你变得更差时，
is rank one. So I think one is the lowest. And there's a person who he made it his personal mission to get to rank one. And people had thought it wasn't even possible and uh he basically you know he actually like walks through like in the beginning he's playing with pretty competitive people because i guess originally like initially he was really good and the people were like pretty mature and and and nice and and you know he was losing all these games um and then he got to like the middle and when he got to about a little worse than average the people became trolls so basically like all the trolls are the people who are like slightly worse than average that's like where most of the trolls are and then when you get even worse it's
有很多机器人，就是那些写了脚本来玩游戏，或者甚至不玩，只是参与游戏，这样他们之后就能得到战利品的人。他不得不像机器人一样输掉比赛，这真的很难做到。所以他花了很多时间试图强迫自己输掉，他最终确实达到了第一名，但这真的是一个很酷的故事。但这不就是那种描述那种等级制度吗？我想我曾经处于那种糟糕的境地，也就是进入一个游戏，不是在它刚出来的时候，而是你知道，过了一段时间，人们一直在谈论它，我心想我会去看看，但当然你作为一个比平均水平差的玩家进入它，你知道，希望如此。是的，然后发生的事情是你开始玩，你就像你说的，和那些喷子一起玩，他们只是从一个游戏跳到另一个游戏，或者无论什么，就像是最差的，而且上面可能真的有一个很好的社区，但你永远无法真正体验它，因为你很容易被低水平的糟糕体验所劝退。
a lot of bots it's people who are have just written scripts to play the game or not even play and participate in the game so that they can get the loot afterwards and he had to like lose the bots which is really hard to do so he spent a ton of time like trying to force himself to lose and he did eventually get to rank one but it's it's a really cool story but isn't that sort of a that described that hierarchy that's i guess i've been on the bad end of that which is coming into a game not when it first comes out but you know after a little while and people have been talking about it and i sort of say i'll check this out but of course you come into it as sort of a worse than average player you know hopefully and uh yeah then what happens is you start playing and you're sort of playing with the people like you said who are the trolls who just go from game to game or whatever and like being the worst and there may
是的，我的意思是，那是一个真正的问题。很难知道如何解决它。但是的，我的意思是，也许，你知道，解决它的方法是拥有一种混合游戏，你知道，你可以有好的和坏的玩家混合，
really be a good community above that but you never really get to experience it because you can easily get turned off of the game by the kind of bad experience at the low level. Yeah, I mean, that's a real problem. It's just hard to know how to solve that. But yeah, that's, I mean, maybe, you know, maybe the way to solve it is to have some kind of hybrid game where, you know, you could have a mix of good and bad players,
而坏玩家不会破坏好玩家的游戏体验。但你必须围绕这一点设计整个游戏。是的，有趣。是的，但与此同时，你可以判断自己是否真的处于游戏低谷，因为人们开始变得非常粗鲁。当人们在《火箭联盟》中对我变得非常粗鲁时，我就知道我正处于连败中。所以我的文章实际上是，一个安全爱好者发现了WannaCry勒索软件的终止开关。我会涵盖所有这些，我其实没有所有细节，Patrick你可能比我了解得多得多，
and the bad players don't ruin the game for the good ones. But you'd have to design the whole game around that. Yeah, interesting. Yeah, but in the meantime, you can tell if you're really in a slump in a game because people start becoming really rude. When people become really rude to me in Rocket League, I know that I'm on a big losing streak. So my article is actually, so a security enthusiast found the kill switch for the WannaCry ransomware. And I'll kind of cover all of this um and i don't have all the details actually patrick you probably know a lot more than me
关于这个，但WannaCry是某种木马或病毒，但基本上它接管了你的电脑，然后你必须支付，你知道，比特币之类的匿名货币给匿名来源才能拿回你的电脑，它通过某种我还没研究过的方式传播，我假设可能是通过电子邮件或Facebook之类的。关于它的一点是，我猜当那个人在测试它时，或者可能只是作为他们自己的终止开关，或者其他什么，有一个特定的域名。这是一个毫无意义的名字。它是www.一堆字符.com。他会向那个域名发送请求，一个Web请求。
on this but uh wanna cry is this uh it's some kind of trojan or virus but uh basically it takes over your computer and then you have to pay you know bitcoin like anonymous money to an anonymous source to get your computer back and it spreads through some way that i haven't looked into i'm assuming it's some kind of maybe over email or facebook or something and the thing about it is i guess when the person was testing it or maybe just as as a kill switch for themselves or what have you, there's a certain domain name. And it's a nonsensical name. It's www.andthenabunchofcharacters.com. And he would send a request to that domain name, a web request.
如果它返回了特定的响应，那么病毒就不会激活。所以即使你的电脑上有病毒，它也不会做任何事。如果他向这个域名发送请求，而没有得到任何回应，那么病毒就会启动。它会锁定你的电脑。它还会尝试传播病毒，以此类推。而一个正在查看病毒，你知道，反编译病毒可执行文件的人，发现了这个逻辑。所以他继续注册了那个域名，这本身就很令人惊讶。就像如果你是黑客，为什么你不早点注册这个域名呢，对吧？但我猜也许那会让你被定罪，但这个人注册了那个域名，并让它返回了适当的结果，他建立了自己执行此操作的Web服务器，他基本上阻止了这个病毒，这很了不起。是的，目前还不清楚为什么
And if it came back with a certain response, then the virus didn't activate. So even though you had the virus on your computer, it wasn't doing anything. If he sends a request to this domain and he doesn't get anything back, then the virus kicks in. It locks your computer down. It also tries to spread the virus, so on and so forth. And somebody who was looking at the virus, you know, decompiling the virus executable, found this logic. And so he went ahead and registered that domain, which is by itself surprising. Like if you were a hacker, why wouldn't you register this domain already, right? But I guess maybe that would incriminate you but uh this person registered that domain and he had it return the appropriate result he built his own web server that did that and he basically stopped this virus which is remarkable yeah it's still unclear why
这些东西里会有那个终止开关，为什么它会那样做，有很多猜测。但是的，我猜最初做这件事的人不确定会发生什么，因为代码很复杂，但他把它作为一个实验，并注意到它确实阻止了代码工作，就像它阻止了病毒安装自己，阻止了勒索软件加密电脑并弹出勒索信息。是的，是的，完全正确。我的意思是，我唯一能想到的是，你知道，测试病毒非常困难。这就是我的猜测，因为即使你在某种虚拟机中，
the stuff had that kill switch in it like why it was doing that there's like a lot of speculation um but yeah i guess the the person who did it originally wasn't sure what would happen because the code's complicated but he he did it as an experiment and noticed it sure enough it stopped the code from work like it stopped the virus from installing itself from uh ransom from encrypting the computer and and putting up the ransom message yeah yeah, yeah, exactly. I mean, the only thing I could think of is, you know, it's very hard to sort of test viruses. That would be my guess, because even if you're in some kind of virtual machine,
你可能必须用某种凭据登录，特别是当你开始在其他机器上测试它时。它可能写这个是为了防止意外地把自己锁在自己的电脑外面。但是的，我的意思是，我猜无论出于什么原因他们选择了它，或者可能只是忘了，他们没有把它删掉，并拯救了很多人巨大的头痛。我想知道有多少人试图编写勒索软件并勒索自己的电脑。是的，我知道，对吧？我的猜测是可能没那么多。你必须非常
you probably have to log in with some kind of credentials and especially when you get to testing it on other machines. And it probably wrote this as a way to keep from accidentally locking themselves out of their own computer but yeah i mean i guess for whatever reason they chose or maybe just forgot and they didn't take it out and and uh um saved a lot of people a huge headache i wonder how many people have attempted to write ransomware and ransom to their own computer yeah i know right my guess is probably not that many you have to be pretty
熟练，所以你可能知道要非常小心。是的，完全正确。我的意思是，我觉得虚拟机可以很好地模拟事物，所以没有理由这样做。但我的意思是，这可能是那种，你知道，是的，如果你粗心一次，你就彻底完蛋了，或者也许你只是付给自己一个比特币，这没关系。哦，给你，那是真的，直到代码不工作了，然后……是的，我不知道，我一直想知道，蠕虫和病毒是否经过了很好的测试，或者不完全是，因为如果它没有经过很好的测试，你就有麻烦了，因为它传播出去了，然后人们会修补他们的系统，你可能无法实现你想要的目标，因为你有意想不到的后果，或者它关闭了本应执行某些操作的服务器。
skilled so you probably know to be really careful yeah exactly i mean i feel like the virtual machine can emulate things so well that there's not really a reason to do it but i mean it could be the kind of thing where you know yeah if you're careless even once you're totally hosed or maybe you just pay yourself a bitcoin it doesn't matter oh there you go that's true until that code's not working right and then yeah yeah i i don't i don't know i always wondered like do the worms and viruses like are they pretty well tested or not really because like if it's not well tested you have a problem because it sort of gets out and then people will patch their systems and you may not accomplish the goal you want because you have unintended consequences or takes down your server that's supposed to be doing whatever
但如果测试得非常好，你真的在乎10%的人的电脑崩溃而不是做你想要的事吗？对吧？是的，我的意思是，归根结底，这并不重要。嗯，但这实际上回到了我们的国际象棋AI例子。分支因子变得非常非常重要。所以即使1%的人没有传播病毒，它最终也会产生巨大的影响。所以是的，我的猜测是它们可能测试得很好。但问题真的是……
but then if you test it really really really well like do you really care if 10 of people's computer crash instead of doing what you want right yeah i mean it's at the end of the day doesn't matter uh well but then it actually gets back to our chess AI example. Like the branching factor becomes really, really important. And so even if 1% of people don't spread the virus, it ends up having a huge impact. So yeah, my guess is probably they're tested pretty well. But the question is really like...
哦，抱歉。哦，你继续。我想说这有点不同。嗯，我跑题了，但被感染的人的顺序本身并不重要。就像如果你没有把它传给我，但Bob把它传给了我，这对我也一样糟糕。
Oh, sorry. Oh, go ahead. I want to say it's sort of different though. Well, I get off on a tangent, but it doesn't matter the order of people being infected per se. Like if you don't spread it to me, but Bob spreads it to me, that's just as bad for me.
就像我不在乎它是来自你还是Bob。是的，是的。我猜那里的问题是，那个图的密度是多少？如果我没有把它传给你，其他人认识你的几率是多少之类的？但是的，我的意思是，实际上我真正好奇的是
Like I don't care that it came from you or Bob. Yeah, yeah. I guess the question there is then like, what is the density of that graph? Like if I don't spread it to you, what are the chances someone else is going to know you or something like that? But yeah, I mean, actually the real thing I'm curious about
这些人是谁？我认为总的来说，它通常是国家支持的。就像各国政府的项目在做这件事。嗯，我想微软站出来了，如果我没记错的话，因为它，你知道，它是在Windows上，站出来说这是WikiLeaks或其他揭露黑客工具缓存的东西的结果，
is who are these people? I think in general, it's usually state sponsored. Like it's government programs of various countries that are doing this. Well, I think Microsoft came out, if I recall, because it was, you know, it was on Windows and came out and said that this was a result of, I think, one of the WikiLeaks or something that revealed the cache of hacker tools
那些工具被使用了。哦，NSA那件事。是的。我们实际上在两期节目之前谈过那个。是的，他们发现显然无论这个漏洞是在那里发现的，所以人们利用它来制造这个。或者至少那是指控。我不知道得不够多，也没有读得足够多，不知道那是否被证明或准确，但明白了。是的，我
that were used. Oh, the NSA thing. Yeah. We actually talked about that like two shows ago. Yeah, and they found that apparently whatever this flaw was found in there, and so people exploited it to make this. Or at least that was the accusation. I don't know enough and didn't read enough about it to know if that was sort of proved out or accurate but gotcha yeah i
读到了一些……是的，我读到了一些类似的内容。所以是的，我猜那些泄露的工具是合法的，也许不是来自NSA或其他什么，但至少它们是……它们绝对是强大的工具，毫无疑问。节目书时间。我的节目书是限时的，所以一定要抓住这个机会。让我看看还剩多少天……在节目发布时，可能还剩大约一周。所以，快点抓住这个机会。这是Humble Bundle的Make Essentials，为了Maker Faire。所以基本上，它只是一堆关于制造东西的书。所以有关于3D打印入门的书，我可能应该读过
read something uh yeah i read something along those lines um so yeah i guess uh i guess that that uh those leaked tools were legit maybe not from the nsa or whatever but at least they were uh it's definitely they were powerful tools there's no doubt about that time for a book of the show book of the show my book of the show is very limited time so uh definitely jump on this um let me see how many days are left uh uh there's probably by the time this show publishes there'll be about a week left so um jump on this quickly. It's the Humble Bundle for Make Essentials, for Maker Faire. So basically, it's just a ton of books about building stuff. So there's books all about getting started with 3D printing that I probably should have read
在我烧掉房子之前。有关于，你知道，设计一个好的工作空间，如何制作可以打印的3D模型的书。有各种各样的，比如电气，你知道，比如机器人，比如自己动手做机器人之类的东西，微控制器，Linux。你可以得到一堆书。你实际上可以用总共一美元得到一堆书。如果你付八美元，你可以得到两倍，如果你付15美元，你可以得到三倍的书。但是的，一定要去看看，这是一个惊人的交易。所有这些Humble图书交易都非常棒。我仍然有问题，我想电子书从来没有真正吸引我。我读过几本，但我太容易分心了。哦，是的。我……是的，我在考虑它。比如我的，虚构类电子书，
before I burn my house down. There's books about, you know, designing a good workspace, how to make 3D models that you can then print. There's all sorts of like electrical, you know, like robotics, like build your own robot kind of thing, microcontrollers, Linux. And you can get a ton of books. You can actually get a ton of books for a dollar total um if you pay eight dollars you get twice as many and if you pay 15 you get three times as many uh books um but yeah definitely check it out it's an amazing deal all of these humble book deals are phenomenal i just still have problems i guess ebooks have never really clicked with me. I've read a couple, but I get too distracted. Oh yeah. I, uh, uh, yeah, I'm thinking about it. Like my, the fiction eBooks,
我肯定读过一堆，至于电子书参考资料。嗯，是的，你是对的。你知道，我有相当多的电子书参考资料，但我不怎么读它们，但也许只是除非我真的卡住了，否则我不怎么读参考书。嗯，我的书是一本巨大的虚构巨著，叫《国王之路》，作者是Brandon Sanderson。这是《飓光志》的第一部，如果我之前推荐过《迷雾之子》系列，结果我起初并不知道这一点，
I've definitely read a bunch of, as far as like eBook references. Um, yeah, you're right. You know, I have, I have a decent amount of eBook references, but, uh, um, I don't read them, read them too much, but maybe it's's just I don't read reference books that much unless I'm really stuck. Well, my book is a massive tome of fiction called The Way of Kings by Brandon Sanderson. And this is book one of the Stormlight Archive, which is if I previously recommended the Mistborn series and it turns out I didn't actually know this at first,
但《国王之路》显然在同一个文学宇宙中。我不知道你怎么说那个。所以它不是那种，这些书，至少据我所知，彼此之间并没有什么关系，但它们存在于Brandon Sanderson称之为Cosmere宇宙的生态系统中。所以我不知道。所以书里有魔法，魔法和《迷雾之子》里的不一样，但在某种程度上很相似。还有另一本书叫《伊兰翠》，显然也设定在这个Cosmere神话中。
but the Way of Kings is apparently in the same book literary universe. I don't know how you say that. So it's not sort of, the books don't, at least as far as I know, don't really have anything to do with each other, but they exist in sort of the same ecosystem of stuff that Brandon Sanderson calls the Cosmere universe. So I don't know. So there's sort of magic in the books and the magic isn't the same as that from Mistborn, but it kind of is similar in a way. There's also another book called Elantris that is apparently also set in this sort of Cosmere mythos.
但所有这些都是说，它是Brandon Sanderson写的，我推荐过好几次，我认为他写得非常好。这本书很长。我实际上，我不知道它有多少页，因为我听了它。但听它，我相信它是……我应该在做这个之前查一下的。但我认为它是30个小时，我想说，或者类似的东西。所以它绝对很长。
But all that's to say that it's by Brandon Sanderson who I've recommended several times and I think he does a really good job of writing. This book is very long. I actually, I don't know how long it is in pages because I listened to it. But the listening to it, I believe it was, I should have looked it up right before I did this. But I think it's like 30 hours, I want to say, or something like that. So it's definitely lengthy.
哦，不，我完全错了，它是45个小时，几乎46个小时。嗯，那是一本普通书的四倍大。46个小时，是的，所以它绝对是一本大书。让我看看能不能算出精装本有多大。嗯，所以它是46个小时，非常长，但我真的很喜欢它。事实上，我有其他一堆书，我想去买第二本，只是因为我太沉迷其中了。但我当时想，在听了45个小时之后，再进入另一本45小时的书，你到最后会有点精疲力竭，所以最好是……180页，啊，是的，很大。但我绝对推荐它，如果
Oh, no, i was completely wrong it's 45 hours for almost 46 hours well that's like four times the size of a normal book 46 hours yeah so it's definitely a big book let's see if i can figure out how big the hardcover is um so it's 46 hours very long but i really really enjoyed it in fact i have a bunch of other books and i wanted to go get the second book just because i was so into it but i was like after i've been burned before after listening to like 45 hours straight to go into another 45 hour book it you kind of get a little burnt out by the end and so it's best to sort of 180 pages ah yeah big um but i definitely recommend it if
噢，不，我完全搞错了，是45小时，差不多46小时。嗯，那大概是普通书的四倍长，46小时，是的，所以这绝对是一本大部头。让我看看能不能查到精装本有多厚。嗯，46小时，非常长，但我真的很喜欢。事实上，我还有很多其他的书，我本来想去买第二本，因为我太沉迷其中了，但我心想，之前有过教训，连续听了45小时之后，再接着听另一本45小时的书，到最后会有点精疲力竭，所以最好还是……180页，啊，是的，很大，但我绝对推荐它，如果
you're into long form fiction at least if you do mostly sort of short stuff. Maybe this is not the best first book because it's quite long. But if you like sort of long, I actually like really long form science fiction and fantasy. I'm in the middle of another very long book by Neil Stevenson, and I'm enjoying it, although this one is starting to drag. So I'm not sure. Maybe I need to go on to a short book kick but anyways the way of kings i know i didn't say anything about what it is because i never know how to talk about stuff without spoiling it um so it totally makes sense check it out it's a fantasy book i guess i mentioned there's some magic that's good i could read like the the back page but you could just do that for yourself on the internet but if you like brian's if you like brandon sanderson or you like fantasy and you have probably already checked it
如果你主要看短篇作品，那你可能对长篇小说不太感兴趣。也许这不是最好的入门书，因为它太长了。但我喜欢长篇科幻和奇幻小说。我正在读尼尔·斯蒂芬森的另一本大部头，读得挺开心，虽然这本开始有点拖沓了。所以我也不确定。也许我该换换口味读点短篇，但不管怎样，《王者之路》——我知道我没说它讲的是什么，因为我从不知道如何在不剧透的情况下谈论这些东西，嗯，所以去看看吧，我想这应该是一本奇幻小说，我提到了里面有一些魔法，这很好，我可以读读封底，但你自己上网也能看到。如果你喜欢布兰登·桑德森，或者你喜欢奇幻小说，你可能已经看过它了。
out because the book is like five years old i think at this point um but if you haven't i give it to my recommendation very cool and you can uh listen to that book on audible and audible is also a sponsor of programming throwdown you can go to audibletrial a sponsor of programming throwdown. You can go to audible trial.com slash programming throwdown and you know, sign up, you get a month free, you get a free book. And if you use that special URL, then you help out the podcast. And I will say 46 hours seems to be a good value for me for that audible credit. $15 for 46 hours. Yeah, definitely um i'm actually reading a book
因为这本书大概已经出版五年了，我想。但如果你还没看过，我强烈推荐，非常棒。你可以去Audible听这本书，Audible也是Programming Throwdown的赞助商。你可以访问audibletrial.com/programmingthrowdown，注册后可以免费获得一个月会员和一本免费书。如果你使用那个特殊的网址，就能支持我们的播客。我得说，用Audible的积分换46小时的听书时长对我来说非常划算。15美元听46小时，确实很值。嗯，我其实正在读一本书。
i won't spoil it uh but um about a third of the way done um and i actually read some books that patrick had recommended in the past on audible since i got my account i read a zero to one um and a couple other books and i think it's. I've actually switched over to that. I can kind of rest my eyes when I'm on the shuttle. Nice. So do you go back to the old show notes and look at my recommendations? I didn't know you were doing this. I feel complimented. That's exactly what I did.
我不会剧透的，嗯，大概读了三分之一吧。自从有了Audible账号，我读了一些帕特里克过去推荐的书，比如《从0到1》还有其他几本，我觉得这很不错。我实际上已经转用这种方式了，在坐班车的时候可以让眼睛休息一下。真不错。那你还会回去翻看以前的节目笔记来找我的推荐吗？我不知道你在这么做，我感到很荣幸。我确实就是这么做的。
Yeah. Have I been a good recommender? You have. Well, you know, I've read some of your recommendations already just on eBook. But, yeah, I picked up some of the ones that you recommended that I hadn't already read and got them on audible but yeah in general i like your recommendation i'm not into into sci-fi so i don't usually uh read the fiction books but uh but uh uh but yeah i feel like your recommendations are solid super interesting um we're also on patreon so you can
是吗？我推荐得好吗？你推荐得很好。嗯，你知道，我已经通过电子书读过你的一些推荐了。但是，是的，我确实挑了一些你推荐过但我还没读过的书，并在Audible上买了。总的来说，我喜欢你的推荐。我不怎么看科幻小说，所以通常不读虚构类书籍，但我觉得你的推荐很扎实，超级有趣。我们也在Patreon上，所以你可以……
go patreon.com slash programming throwdown um you can give us a shout out, send us a message. You can also set up a donation, like become a Patreon to Programming Throwdown. We really appreciate that. At the end of the year, every year, we take any money left over after our server costs and everything else. And we give out free t-shirts to people who are subscribers.
访问patreon.com/programmingthrowdown，你可以给我们留言，发消息。你也可以设置捐款，成为Programming Throwdown的Patreon赞助人。我们非常感谢。每年年底，我们会把支付服务器费用和其他开支后剩下的钱，拿出来给订阅者买免费的T恤。
And yeah, check it out. We also publish a separate rss feed there that's has a bit more bandwidth so if you're a subscriber um you can use that rss feed yep time for tool of the show okay so my tool of show has a bit of backstory um while i was buying this 3d printer from china i also noticed china has a bunch of other stuff for sale that is super cheap. You fell down a rabbit hole. Yes, it is a rabbit hole. And I bought a tablet.
去看看吧。我们还在那里发布了一个单独的RSS订阅源，带宽更高，所以如果你是订阅者，可以使用那个RSS源。好了，现在是“本期工具”时间。好的，我的本期工具背后有一段小故事。当我在中国买这个3D打印机时，我注意到中国还有很多其他东西在卖，而且超级便宜。你掉进兔子洞了。是的，这确实是个兔子洞。我买了一个平板电脑。
I've been wanting this for a long time. I've been wanting a gigantic tablet. I wanted a tablet so big that I could read an 8.5 by 11 research paper, you know, at scale. That was the goal. But I don't want to spend a lot of money. I could get like an iPad Pro, but I think it's like $1,200 or something for the big one. Or maybe it's like $1,000, but it's still a lot of money.
我想要这个很久了。我一直想要一个巨大的平板电脑。我想要一个大到可以按原比例阅读8.5乘11英寸研究论文的平板。这就是我的目标。但我不想花太多钱。我可以买iPad Pro，但大尺寸的那款好像要1200美元左右。或者可能是1000美元，但那依然是一大笔钱。
So a Chinese dropshipper was shipping a 12-inch Android tablet. It actually runs Android and Windows. What? what it's dual boots yeah isn't that wild when it starts up it has used the volume up and volume down button to choose whether you want windows or android whichever you're feeling that day yeah and it's amazing un-freaking-believable and it was only 200 oh wow this huge tablet, this beautiful screen. The only catch, it runs a fork of Android, and if you just put stock Android on it,
所以有个中国的代发货商在卖一款12英寸的安卓平板。它实际上同时运行安卓和Windows系统。什么？它是双系统的？是的，这不疯狂吗？启动时，你可以用音量加减键来选择进入Windows还是安卓，看你那天想用哪个。是的，这太神奇了，简直不可思议，而且只要200美元。哦，哇，这个巨大的平板，这漂亮的屏幕。唯一的缺点是，它运行的是安卓的一个分支版本，如果你直接刷入原生安卓系统……
the touchscreen doesn't work. I saw that from reading the internet. So I have to leave the version of Android on, and it also has Chinese spyware. So it had this thing called AdOps that I've read on the internet. I haven't verified, but according to the internet, it logs your keystrokes, like your keyboard touches.
触摸屏就不能用了。我是从网上读到这个的。所以我必须保留原版的安卓系统，而且它还带有中国间谍软件。它有一个叫AdOps的东西，我在网上读到过。我还没验证过，但根据网上的说法，它会记录你的按键，也就是你的键盘输入。
So when I found that out, I was super bummed. I thought I had this paperweight, or at least I was going to have to highly regulate my usage. But then I found this app called, this program called Deep Loader. So you run this on your desktop with an Android device plugged in. And even the factory level services, you can turn them off. You can't uninstall them because you don't have root access, but you can disable them. You can disable their connections to internet, you can turn them off. You can't uninstall them because you don't have root access, but you can disable them. You can disable their connections to internet. You can turn them off entirely. And so I ran this dbloater and I turned off add-ups on my tablet.
当我发现这一点时，我非常沮丧。我以为我买了个镇纸，或者至少我得严格限制它的使用。但后来我找到了一个叫Deep Loader的程序。你可以在电脑上运行它，连接安卓设备。即使是工厂预装的服务，你也可以把它们关掉。你不能卸载它们，因为你没有Root权限，但你可以禁用它们。你可以禁用它们连接互联网，可以彻底关闭它们。所以我运行了这个Deep Loader，关掉了平板上的AdOps。
And the other thing I found out is a lot of these lesser named brands, like the BLU, Blue Android Phones, and some of these other Chinese brands, which have sold just millions and millions of devices in the US, have this spyware on them. And so if you have, you know, if you have one of the major ones, like if you have a Motorola or a Samsung, you're fine. But if you bought, you know, either for yourself or for your family, one of these like other brands like Blue
我还发现很多这些小众品牌，比如BLU，Blue安卓手机，以及其他一些在中国卖了数百万台设备的品牌，都有这种间谍软件。所以如果你用的是主流品牌，比如摩托罗拉或三星，那就没问题。但如果你为你自己或家人买了这些其他品牌，比如Blue……
or, or, uh, uh, Chewy or one of these Chinese brands, then, uh, run this deep loader or even if you didn't run the deep loader. And, and, uh, and I think all Verizon phones also have some type of logging system, um, that it doesn't log keystrokes like it's not that invasive but you could you could disable it with this program so have you been reading research papers on your gigantic tablet i have yeah it's actually it's really nice um i have an app called moon reader it's kind of expensive it's like five bucks for a pdf reader so you So it seems kind of like a waste, but it's amazing. It lets you annotate on the PDF pretty easily. It'll actually switch to night mode and it'll invert the colors of the PDF. So even the pictures, the colors will be kind of inverted. And yeah, it makes the pictures kind of strange, but for a research paper where you're really just looking at graphs, it's
或者Chewy，或者其他中国品牌，那就运行这个Deep Loader。即使你没运行Deep Loader，我想所有的Verizon手机也都有某种记录系统，它不会像那样记录按键，没那么具有侵入性，但你可以用这个程序禁用它。所以你一直在用你的巨型平板读研究论文吗？是的，确实很棒。我有一个叫Moon Reader的App，有点贵，PDF阅读器要5美元左右。所以……这看起来有点浪费，但它太棒了。它让你能很方便地在PDF上做批注。它甚至可以切换到夜间模式，反转PDF的颜色。即使是图片，颜色也会被反转。是的，这会让图片看起来有点奇怪，但对于主要看图表的研究论文来说，这……
okay. And that makes it much easier on their eyes and everything so yeah it's uh it's it's really nice my tool of the show predictably is an iphone app i don't actually think well i i should say an ios app because i know it's on the ipad as well but i don't it didn't look like it was available at least not yet for android devices um and this is card thief this is by the same um person company that created card crawl which i think i've recommended before uh if not it's also a cool game check i think it's a couple dollars and card thief is a strategic card game oh no it does say it's on Android. Okay, cool. Yep. It's on Android. All right, cool I feel bad didn't wanna leave those people out Anyways, so this this is a strategic card game where you are sort of a thief sneaking around
没问题。这让阅读对眼睛更友好，所以这真的很棒。我的本期工具不出所料是一个iPhone App。其实我不应该这么说，应该说是iOS App，因为我知道它在iPad上也能用，但看起来它在安卓设备上还不可用。这就是《卡牌窃贼》（Card Thief），它是由创造了《卡牌爬行》（Card Crawl）的同一个人/公司开发的，我想我之前推荐过。如果没有的话，这也是个很酷的游戏，只要几美元。《卡牌窃贼》是一款策略卡牌游戏。哦，不，它确实显示有安卓版。好的，酷。是的，它有安卓版。好吧，酷，我感到很抱歉，不想把那些人排除在外。总之，这是一款策略卡牌游戏，你扮演一个小偷，在……
Buildings trying to avoid lights and guards and trying to get to the exit all by sort of managing Your stats so that you can get good scores, pick up loot, all that kind of stuff. And I thought it's just sort of fun to see a card game that – I have several implementations of real card games that I've played, but it's interesting to see people playing – simulating playing a real card game, but in a way where it would be like this card game would never exist in real life because it would be too tedious or too much bookkeeping that no one would ever really want to play it.
建筑物里潜行，试图避开灯光和守卫，并设法到达出口，所有这些都需要通过管理你的属性来获得高分、收集战利品等等。我觉得看到一款卡牌游戏很有趣——我玩过很多现实中卡牌游戏的电子版，但看到人们玩——模拟玩一种现实中存在的卡牌游戏，但方式却是这种卡牌游戏在现实中永远不会存在，因为它太繁琐或需要太多记录，没人会真的想玩，这很有趣。
It's just sort of an interesting genre. And anyways, yeah, check out Card Deep. There's other games as well that I play where I didn't like the idea of it in a real board game where I'd played things similar and just like sort of the tediousness of it made it not interesting to me. But then playing on the iPad,
这是一种有趣的类型。总之，去看看《卡牌窃贼》吧。我玩的其他游戏中，有些在现实桌游中我并不喜欢，因为玩过类似的，那种繁琐感让我觉得没意思。但在iPad上玩……
you can sort of sit down and it like shuffles for you. It keeps track of all of your statistics and make sure you don't sort of break the rules by accident so some games that are really fun but sometimes are sort of easy to mess up or make great ipad or i i mean just great app implementations yeah totally yeah especially like agricola and these games that have just so much going on so much more fun on the ipad but it's so fun to move all those bits of wood around in Agricola. I don't know what you're talking about. The app doesn't do it for me.
你可以坐下来，它会自动为你洗牌。它会记录你所有的统计数据，确保你不会意外违反规则。所以有些游戏虽然很有趣，但有时容易出错，做成iPad App或者说App实现就非常棒。是的，完全同意。特别是像《农场主》（Agricola）这种内容极其丰富的游戏，在iPad上玩要有趣得多。但我就是喜欢在《农场主》里移动那些小木块。我不知道你在说什么，App对我来说没那种感觉。
I don't know why. It's just like I love moving the little bits around, but it does make it hard to get to the table. I actually think, yeah, if I just had an app where I could take a picture of the board at the end and it would kind of like a score, that's all I really need. Fair enough, fair enough fair enough alright well time to talk about
我不知道为什么。我就是喜欢移动那些小零件，但这确实让它很难搬上桌。我其实觉得，如果我有一个App，能在游戏结束时拍张照就能计分，那我就满足了。有道理，有道理。好吧，是时候谈谈……
code reviews this is going to be an exciting and most thrilling topic ever this is I think the interesting thing about this is you know if we talk about let's say Python you're going to learn it in college or maybe even in high school
代码审查了。这将是一个最令人兴奋和激动的话题。我认为这其中有趣的地方在于，你知道，如果我们谈论Python，你会在大学甚至高中学到它……
and you're going to learn it in college or maybe even in high school. And you're going to go into your first software engineer job, probably already knowing Python. But this is something that, like, it's a chicken and an egg. Like, you can't really know it until you've done it or until, you know, someone kind of covers the whole process. And a lot of colleges, you know, we had a college course called software architecture. And it was, you know, it really should have covered things like code reviews, but it didn't.
你会在大学甚至高中学到它。然后你会进入第一份软件工程师工作，可能已经掌握了Python。但这是一件像“先有鸡还是先有蛋”的事情。你如果不亲身经历，或者没人带你走一遍整个流程，你是不可能真正掌握它的。很多大学，我们有一门叫软件架构的课程。它真的应该涵盖代码审查之类的内容，但它没有。
So we actually didn't really get a taste for, you know, code reviews and merging and releasing code and these things until we got into industry. And so hopefully Patrick and I are going to change that right now. Yeah, I guess I knew it existed. But, you know, anyways, I didn't really know what it was. And it's actually surprising to me. A lot of people, a lot of companies don't have good code review systems or aren't even practicing code review, which is kind of crazy to me. So I felt like this was a good opportunity to talk about, yeah, there's a bunch of reasons why you wouldn't want to do it, but there's a whole lot more reasons why you would want to do it and i personally like at this point feel that if i don't get code review i feel like i'm not done yet like i i feel like you're not done until you write at least some
所以我们直到进入行业后，才真正体验到代码审查、合并和发布代码这些事情。希望帕特里克和我现在能改变这一点。是的，我想我知道它存在。但是，总之，我并不真正了解它是什么。这让我很惊讶。很多人，很多公司都没有好的代码审查系统，甚至根本不进行代码审查，这对我来说简直不可思议。所以我认为这是一个谈论它的好机会。是的，有很多理由让你不想做代码审查，但有更多理由让你想做。我个人现在觉得，如果我不进行代码审查，我就觉得工作还没完成。我觉得除非你写了至少一定……
amount of unit tests and uh and get code review yep totally um anyways so i already was talking about implying why you would do code review so one of them is get someone else to look at your code. I mean, there's a lot of times where I've written things that were sort of bad assumptions and even kind of past unit tests because I also wrote my unit test from the sort of same point of view. And someone else will point out like, what in the world are you doing here? And it's really important to get another pair of eyes for, for several reasons. One,
数量的单元测试并进行了代码审查，否则就不算完成。是的，完全同意。总之，我已经暗示了为什么要进行代码审查。其中之一是让别人看看你的代码。有很多次，我写的东西基于一些错误的假设，甚至通过了单元测试，因为我的单元测试也是从同样的视角写的。而别人会指出：“你在这里到底在做什么？”获得另一双眼睛来审视是非常重要的，原因有几个。第一……
you just, you can miss stuff to, you know, as a engineer, I feel like it's, and I was describing this to someone is like, I feel like good engineers are very, very open about what they do.
你可能会漏掉一些东西。作为一名工程师，我觉得，我曾向某人描述过，我觉得优秀的工程师对他们所做的事情非常、非常开放。
They don't try to keep secrets. They don't try to keep hidden kind of like methods. They are very open, very sharing. And part of that is that way. And this sounds bad, but everyone can share in the blame, which is like when something goes wrong, it's not just the person who wrote the code's fault. It's the process's fault.
他们不试图保守秘密。他们不试图隐藏方法。他们非常开放，乐于分享。部分原因在于，这听起来可能不好，但每个人都可以分担责任。这意味着当事情出错时，不仅仅是写代码的人的错，也是流程的错。
It's the people who reviewed the code. And that sounds like you're trying to look for ways to blame other people, but it's not. It's about it really, some of the stuff we do is almost too important for just one person to be doing. And so really you need to have more sets of eyes on that and code review is a is a great way to do that and have a understanding about the process of going from writing code and getting it deployed and shipped um and so yeah and i mean also people want to do different things i mean if you if you keep this you know chunk of code to yourself then you have to be its babysitter for as long as you work at that company.
是那些审查代码的人的错。这听起来好像你在找借口推卸责任，但事实并非如此。这真的关乎……我们所做的一些事情太重要了，不能只由一个人来完成。所以你确实需要更多的人来审视，代码审查是一个很好的方式，可以让你理解从编写代码到部署和发布的过程。而且，人们也想做不同的事情。如果你把这块代码据为己有，那么只要你在那家公司工作，你就得一直当它的保姆。
Well, some people see that as an advantage. Yeah, we're talking about good soft pages. I don't know. I've been hard-pressed to find a situation where that was truly good. Yeah, I mean, there's people who say, oh, you know, it's job security if I'm the only person who knows the code base. It really doesn't work that way. Like, it's pretty easy to rewrite stuff from scratch. It might not be easy, you know, for a person to do it, but for a company, it's pretty easy.
嗯，有些人把这看作一种优势。是的，我们是在谈论优秀的软件工程师。我不知道。我很难找到一种情况，这真的是件好事。是的，有些人说，哦，如果只有我一个人了解代码库，这就是工作保障。其实根本不是那样。重写代码其实很容易。对个人来说可能不容易，但对公司来说，这很容易。
And it's much better to, as Patrick said, yeah, be open and write the best possible code rather than try and optimize for job security. Yeah. And along exactly the same lines is you really want to be able to, you know, it's the, you know, bus insurance. It's like if someone on your team walks out and on the way home and gets hit by a bus, you want to make sure you know what they're doing. And one of the good ways to do that is through code review, because other people on the team will be seeing the code that that person is writing and, you know and understanding what they're doing. Also sort of prevents people from just kind of not ever paying attention to what you do. And so make sure that people sort of have visibility into the work you're doing, good or bad, but hopefully the good work that you're doing.
而且正如帕特里克所说，保持开放并写出尽可能好的代码，比试图通过这种方式来保障工作要好得多。是的。同样道理，你确实需要能够，你知道，这就是“公交车保险”。如果你的团队中有人在下班路上被公交车撞了，你要确保你知道他们在做什么。而实现这一点的好方法之一就是通过代码审查，因为团队中的其他人会看到那个人写的代码，并理解他们在做什么。这也防止了人们从不关注你所做的事情。所以要确保人们对你的工作有可见度，无论好坏，但希望是你所做的出色工作。
And so they can kind of like help recommend you when performance reviews come around or whatever. Yeah, makes sense. There are some definite caveats so things where code review can go wrong so one of them is you can get people on your team who for one reason or another uh you know like to slow things down or they want to land something you know they want to check in some code before you get it in and so they start to try to be kind of a roadblock. And one of the symptoms of this is people who get really, really nitpicky about very, very small things like the grammatical structure of your comments. Or in code review is not the time to decide whether your company or your team is going to use tabs or spaces.
这样当绩效评估到来时，他们可以为你推荐。是的，有道理。当然也有一些明确的注意事项，即代码审查可能出错的地方。其中之一是，你的团队中可能会有人因为某种原因喜欢拖慢进度，或者他们想在你的代码合并之前先提交自己的代码，所以他们开始试图成为一种阻碍。这种症状之一是，人们对非常细小的事情变得非常挑剔，比如注释的语法结构。代码审查不是决定你的公司或团队应该使用制表符还是空格的时候。
I mean, those code reviews do not work well for those things um those should be decided i guess we call it side channel or outside of the code review system um code review is also not a good time for like architectural work at like a big level that should also be communicated in an external way when you go time to have your review your code review people should already know sort of like the context of your code um now there may still be needs to critique some of the architectural decisions at like a tactical level on your code but not you know people should know why you sat down to write that code for the most part right totally um the other thing is you know the team has to be diligent about code reviews equally because if some people are really into it and some people
我的意思是，代码审查不适合处理这些事情。这些应该在所谓的“侧信道”或代码审查系统之外决定。代码审查也不是进行大规模架构工作的时机，这应该通过外部方式沟通。当你进行代码审查时，人们应该已经了解你代码的背景。当然，在战术层面上批评一些架构决策可能仍然有必要，但人们应该知道你为什么坐下来写这段代码，大部分情况下是这样，对吧？完全同意。另一件事是，团队必须同样勤奋地进行代码审查。因为如果有些人非常热衷，而有些人……
aren't you can end up with a problem of like the very eager person has code out for review but nobody else is eager about it and so they don't do the reviews in a timely manner and then that becomes a problem for various reasons and it's on the same token like on some teams i've been on it's sort of one or two people are very passionate about sort of code cleanliness and code health and they end up doing sort of the vast majority of the code reviews or have to be a part of all the code reviews. And there's a bunch of other people who don't do it. And I find that to not be good. That never ends up working well in the long term. Yeah, that makes sense. I think, yeah, to have a good code review kind of process, you have to have a good auto formatter. Because
不热衷，你最终会遇到问题，比如非常积极的人有代码等待审查，但其他人并不积极，所以他们没有及时进行审查，这就会因为各种原因成为问题。同样，在我待过的一些团队中，有一两个人对代码整洁度和健康度非常热衷，他们最终承担了绝大多数代码审查，或者必须参与所有的代码审查。而其他很多人根本不做。我发现这并不好。从长远来看，这永远不会奏效。是的，有道理。我认为，要拥有良好的代码审查流程，必须有一个好的自动格式化工具。因为……
yeah, I've seen so many code reviews devolve into like oh add a space here put a comma here and and uh you know that ends up wasting like a lot of human time when you could have just written a program and some regexes and and you know or used clang format or something um so, if you don't have an auto formatter, then that should be your first priority. Or at least a linter. Yeah, that's true. Or at least a linter that won't let you
是的，我见过太多代码审查演变成“哦，这里加个空格，那里加个逗号”，这最终浪费了大量人力，而你本可以用程序、正则表达式，或者使用Clang Format之类的工具来解决。所以，如果你没有自动格式化工具，那应该是你的首要任务。或者至少是一个代码检查工具（Linter）。是的，没错。或者至少是一个如果不通过所有风格检查就不让你开始代码审查的Linter。然后，正如帕特里克所说，代码审查实际上是……如果你认为整个架构需要彻底重构，那是另一项任务。代码审查实际上是……
even start the code review without passing all the style checks. And then yeah, as Patrick said, the code review is really, if you think that the whole architecture needs to be overhauled, that's a separate task. The code review is really, you know, if you think that the whole architecture needs to be overhauled, that's a separate task. The code review is really, you know, is there a bug that this person didn't see? Or are they, did they introduce a bad architecture that's going to sort of spiral out of control that, you know, just materialized in that code review?
是否有这个人没看到的Bug？或者他们是否引入了糟糕的架构，导致失控，而这在代码审查中才显现出来？
But it's not the place to say, oh, you know, I realize maybe we shouldn't have pointers anymore. Like that's not the thing you deal with in a code review. Definitely, yeah. So, you know, one, there's many different ways to do code reviews. At the end of the day, you know, they all involve kind of, you know, soliciting feedback and receiving feedback. So it's really they parallel sort of the way you communicate. I mean, you could just, a simple way is to just zip up your code, email it to someone, and they'll email you back some feedback.
但这不是说“哦，我意识到也许我们不应该再使用指针了”的地方。那不是你在代码审查中处理的事情。绝对是这样。所以，有很多不同的方式来进行代码审查。归根结底，它们都涉及征求反馈和接收反馈。所以它们实际上与你的沟通方式平行。你可以简单地把代码压缩，通过电子邮件发给某人，他们会回信给你一些反馈。
You could also go in person. Like, you could have, call someone over to your desk and just kind of, and I've actually done this, even at companies where we had good tools. If I see that there's some kind of back and forth and it's not really going anywhere, then I'll just go to that person and I'll say, hey, can you just come to my desk and we'll just in person, we'll step through this.
你也可以亲自去。你可以叫某人到你的办公桌前，我确实这样做过，即使在有良好工具的公司也是如此。如果我看到某种来回沟通并没有什么进展，我就会直接去找那个人说：“嘿，你能来我桌前吗？我们当面过一遍。”
Yeah, I do that same reason. Like if I feel, not if something's gonna be contentious per se, but like if I think something is gonna potentially cause a bunch of questions, I'll bring people over in advance and sort of, you know, walk them through and solicit the suggestions in person.
是的，我出于同样的原因也会这样做。如果我觉得，不是说事情会有争议，而是如果我觉得某件事可能会引起一堆问题，我会提前把人叫过来，当面引导他们并征求建议。
Yep. Yeah, totally. In person is actually really, really useful. This is kind of a side note, but if ever, you know, an email thread, let's say goes back and forth between the same two people, let's say more than twice, then you need to schedule a meeting. And the same is true for code reviews. Like if you say, oh, I think it should be.h, and the person says, no, it should be.hpp, and you say, oh, well, here's a link to Stack Overflow, or they say it should be.h. At that point, it needs to be done in person because those just don't really end well. And then last, they have a ton of different web tools they're super powerful this is this is the recommended way to do 99% of code reviews I don't have a particular preference fabricator is a good one Garrett is another one if
是的，完全同意。当面沟通真的非常有用。这算是一个题外话，但如果同一个邮件主题在两个人之间来回超过两次，那么你就需要安排一个会议了。代码审查也是如此。如果你说“我觉得应该是.h文件”，对方说“不，应该是.hpp”，你说“哦，这是Stack Overflow的链接”，或者他们说“应该是.h”。在那一点上，它需要当面解决，因为这些争论通常不会有好的结果。最后，他们有很多不同的Web工具，功能非常强大。这是推荐进行99%代码审查的方式。我没有特别的偏好，Phabricator是一个不错的选择，Gerrit是另一个，如果……
you're using github the private gith, or if you're doing an open source project, or using the GitLab or Bitbucket or any of these tools, they have often a code review tool built into the whatever source control tool you're using. So that's good as well. At a high level, the web tools break down into two categories. One is it's basically just a better way to do the email version. Like you would send someone a link. They could click on the link. They could see sort of a graphical view of your code.
你正在使用GitHub，或者如果你在做一个开源项目，或者使用GitLab、Bitbucket或任何这些工具，它们通常在所使用的源代码控制工具中内置了代码审查工具。所以这也很好。从高层来看，Web工具分为两类。一类基本上只是电子邮件方式的改进版。就像你给某人发送一个链接。他们可以点击链接，看到代码的图形化视图。
They can make comments right there. But it's basically the same as the email. The other way, you know, the GitHub way is where you actually make a merge request. And this sort of combines the code review with the kind of merge itself, all kind of in one step. So someone's approving the quality of the code and also the fact that this code belongs in this code base right now. And I think both are equally good. So I think there's 100 ways to skin the cat, but the important thing is to do the code reviews.
他们可以直接在上面发表评论。但这基本上和电子邮件是一样的。另一种方式，也就是GitHub的方式，是你实际上发起了一个合并请求（Merge Request）。这结合了代码审查和合并本身，都在一个步骤中完成。所以有人在批准代码质量，同时也批准这段代码现在属于这个代码库。我认为两者都同样好。所以我觉得条条大路通罗马，但重要的是要进行代码审查。
I will say that having some sort of web tool is enormously helpful. I've been in a couple teams mostly a while ago. I think there's become better support for it recently, but where in-person code review used to be the way to do it and everyone was expected to read the code in advance and sort of come with a set of questions or comments. And just like the sheer amount of bookkeeping
我得说，拥有某种Web工具是非常有帮助的。我曾在几个团队待过，主要是很久以前，我想最近对它的支持已经变好了，但那时当面代码审查是惯例，每个人都被要求提前阅读代码，并带着一堆问题或评论来。而仅仅是那种繁琐的记录工作……
and lack of desire to go through the code in advance really makes it a drag where I really felt the quality of code reviews was much poorer with that approach. Now, as Jason said, using in-person, yeah, using in-person to supplement, yeah, definitely. But as like the only way, yeah, I'm not so sure. Yeah, yeah, totally. I think, you know, 90% of code reviews should be done, yeah, either email or with one of these web tools. And the web tools are far faster. Most of them are integrated with your source control. So some of them them you literally just type
以及缺乏提前阅读代码的意愿，真的让它变得很拖沓。我确实觉得那种方式的代码审查质量要差得多。现在，正如杰森所说，使用当面沟通作为补充，是的，绝对可以。但作为唯一的方式，我不太确定。是的，完全同意。我认为90%的代码审查应该通过电子邮件或这些Web工具完成。Web工具要快得多。它们大多数都与你的源代码控制集成在一起。所以有些工具你只需要输入……
in a command and boom the code review is done like type in a command with a few people's names and it does all the work for you um so you know part of this is if you're uh you know running your own company or running your own team you have have to, you know, kind of set some guidelines for code reviews. You know, one kind of nice guideline is this idea that everything has to be reviewed. I think this is, in general, a good strategy. I mean, almost everywhere, I think literally everywhere I've worked at has had this strategy,
一个命令，砰，代码审查就完成了。输入一个命令，带上几个人的名字，它就为你完成了所有的工作。所以，如果你在经营自己的公司或团队，你必须设定一些代码审查的准则。一个不错的准则是：所有代码都必须经过审查。我认为这通常是一个好的策略。我的意思是，几乎我工作过的每一个地方，字面上每一个地方，都有这个策略。
you know, that you can't just start making changes. Now you can do like an emergency change if let's say it's 2am and you're, you get paged and you have to fix something right now. But even then, if you do one of these sort of emergency commits, that's not reviewed, it should send some kind of email so that someone can review it later. I have been at places which didn't have this rule and i think the problem is making lots of little change there's sort of a tendency for people to make a bunch of little changes which they claim are not contentious or don't need review
你不能直接开始做改动。当然，如果凌晨2点你收到寻呼，必须立即修复某些东西，你可以进行紧急修改。但即使那样，如果你进行了这种未经审查的紧急提交，也应该发送某种邮件，以便以后有人可以审查它。我待过一些没有这条规则的地方，我认为问题在于人们倾向于做很多小改动，声称这些改动没有争议或不需要审查。
but then over time they build up into something that really ought to have been reviewed and sort of flies under the radar because no change was too big. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah. Yeah, I think also in addition to just code reviews, it's good to have these architectural reviews and things like that. Those are usually done in person. Like if you want to propose kind of a new kind of high level feature and things like that.
但随着时间的推移，它们积累起来，变成了真正应该被审查的东西，却因为没有哪一次改动太大而逃过了审查。是的，有道理。我也认为，除了代码审查，进行架构审查之类的事情也很好。这些通常是当面进行的。比如你想提议某种新的高层功能之类的事情。
Some places have this idea called readability. And so this is where you get somebody on your team or someone in your department who's really, really good at Python, let's say. And he's on the code review, but he's not really there to see if your code is doing what you are tasked to do. He's just there to look at the syntax and look at if you're using the language in the right way and things like that. So there's some companies who have that. Another thing is, you know, some policies, some companies say, you know, have one person approved. Some say have two people approved. I generally think one person is fine. I don't really see why you have to get two people to approve it, but maybe it depends. If some code is really mission critical, then it's good to have, you know, as you add more pairs of eyes, you're going to catch more and more bugs.
有些地方有“可读性”的概念。这就是你找团队中或部门里非常擅长Python的人，让他参与代码审查，但他不是为了看你的代码是否完成了任务，他只是为了看语法，看你是否以正确的方式使用语言等等。有些公司有这种做法。另一件事是，有些政策，有些公司说需要一个人批准，有些说需要两个人批准。我通常认为一个人就够了。我不明白为什么非要两个人批准，但这可能取决于情况。如果某些代码是任务关键型的，那么拥有更多的人来审视是好的，因为你会发现越来越多的Bug。
Well, I've seen requiring two people in a way like a kind of more, like a more senior person working with a more junior person. The more junior person may have more context on that specific thing, but you may want another sort of senior person to approve the change overall. But you still want the feedback from the more junior person because they have some contextual awareness or vice versa. Oh, yeah, that makes sense. That makes sense. So basically, some people have more power than other people or a similar way of saying that. Yeah, I think another kind of rule is you try to keep the code reviews relatively small.
嗯，我见过要求两个人批准的情况，这更像是一种资深人员与初级人员的合作。初级人员可能对那个具体事物有更多背景，但你可能希望另一位资深人员批准整体变更。但你仍然希望得到初级人员的反馈，因为他们有某种背景意识，反之亦然。哦，是的，有道理。有道理。所以基本上，有些人比其他人有更大的权力，或者用类似的方式说。是的，我认为另一个规则是尽量保持代码审查的规模相对较小。
So if, for example, so one thing that's really important a lot of people know about is you can often, when you're using, let's say, Git, you can do git add dash p, and it will let you add part of your changes to a commit. So let's say, for example, I implemented a new way to get the index of some item,
所以，例如，很多人都知道的一件重要事情是，当你使用Git时，你可以使用“git add -p”，它允许你将部分更改添加到提交中。所以，例如，我实现了一种获取某项索引的新方法……
but then I also took this other part of the code and made it 10 times faster because I had to to support the other thing. Well, those are really two different things. They might be tied together, but functionally they're two different functions. You could have the speedup without having the first thing. And so that's where something like a git add-p
但我同时也拿了代码的另一部分，并将其速度提高了10倍，因为为了支持前一个功能我必须这样做。嗯，这实际上是两件不同的事情。它们可能联系在一起，但在功能上是两个不同的函数。你可以在没有第一件事的情况下实现加速。这就是像“git add -p”……
or the equivalent of whatever source control you're using, like in Mercurial it's hg-split, is super useful because you could take part of it and You can make that a code review. Like, hey, Bob, can you review this speed up? I ran all the tests. They all give the same answer, but it's way faster. Can you look at this? Are there any mistakes?
或者你所使用的任何源代码控制工具的等效功能（比如Mercurial中的“hg split”）非常有用的地方，因为你可以取出一部分，把它变成一个代码审查。比如，“嘿，鲍勃，你能审查一下这个加速吗？我运行了所有的测试，结果都一样，但速度快多了。你能看看吗？有什么错误吗？”
And then you could take the other half and you could give that to someone else or give it to Bob, too, but at least as a separate code review, um, that makes it, it makes it way better to read and, and, uh, makes it way more likely you'll get your reviews accepted. Yeah. And there's nothing worse than having someone work for like, uh, like a month or however long, like a long period of time, get a giant code review. And then you have some like, sort of naming, you know, questions or clarifications or style change and then the person like the size of the code that they have to go fix when that comment comes in is just preponderous on top of it's just really daunting to sit down and be like i have to go through many thousands lines of code for this review it makes it very hard to sit down and do the review yeah exactly
然后你可以把另一半给别人，或者也给鲍勃，但至少作为单独的代码审查。这让阅读变得容易得多，也更有可能让你的审查被接受。是的，没有什么比让某人工作了一个月或很长一段时间，然后得到一个巨大的代码审查更糟糕的了。然后你有一些命名问题、澄清或风格更改，当那个评论进来时，那个人必须去修复的代码量简直太庞大了。坐下来面对几千行代码的审查确实非常令人望而生畏。是的，完全正确。
um the other part is uh another thing to mention is, I think we've talked about this before, but if you find a bug in a piece of code, there's an extremely high chance there's another bug in that same code. It's just, I don't think there's a name for this. It's some phenomena, but basically, you know, it's sort of like if you have the wrong mindset that created a bug somewhere, you created a lot of bugs in that place almost for sure and so by having the code reviews be kind of atomic you know if one code review um is having some problems uh you can really focus on that
嗯，另一部分是，还要提到的一点是，我想我们之前谈过这个，但如果你在一段代码中发现了一个Bug，那么在同一段代码中存在另一个Bug的可能性极高。这只是，我不认为这有个名字。这是一种现象，但基本上，如果你有某种错误的思维方式导致了某个地方的Bug，那么你几乎肯定在那个地方制造了很多Bug。所以通过让代码审查变得原子化，如果一个代码审查……
and you're not blocking all these other code reviews so yeah that's code reviews in a nutshell. It sounds very kind of Dilbert-esque, right? It sounds like TPS reports from, you know, office space or whatever. But it's actually, it's super important. Look at it as sort of a way of communicating, a way of sort of telling people what you're doing, getting feedback, giving feedback. I've definitely seen, especially now that they keep coming out with new versions of C++, I definitely see things in the code that I didn't even knew were possible.
出现了一些问题，你可以真正专注于那个问题，而不会阻塞所有其他代码审查。所以，这就是代码审查的精髓。这听起来很像《呆伯特》（Dilbert），对吧？听起来像《办公空间》（Office Space）里的TPS报告之类的。但实际上，它非常重要。把它看作一种沟通方式，一种告诉人们你在做什么、获得反馈、给予反馈的方式。我绝对见过，特别是现在C++不断推出新版本，我确实在代码中看到了我以前甚至不知道可能存在的东西。
And so it's made me a better programmer and it's highly recommended. Yeah, I also want to say thank you to all of our listeners and all the people who have been sending us feedback, doing reviews, using our A audible trial or donating on Patreon. We've been getting an enormous amount of support and we just want to say thank you to all of our listeners. Yeah, definitely.
所以它让我成为了一个更好的程序员，强烈推荐。是的，我也想感谢我们所有的听众，以及所有给我们发送反馈、进行评论、使用我们的Audible试用或在Patreon上捐款的人。我们得到了巨大的支持，我们只想对所有的听众说声谢谢。是的，绝对的。
Thank you. And keep writing in. We try to answer every email and I think we're doing a pretty good job. We're mostly we had a bit of a backlog. We're mostly caught up now. So thank you for all your feedback and we'll see you next month. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work,
谢谢。请继续写信给我们。我们尽量回答每一封邮件，我想我们做得还不错。我们之前积压了一些，现在基本赶上了。所以感谢你们所有的反馈，我们下个月见。Programming Throwdown是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可下发布的。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行重混、改编……
but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I, and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但你必须注明帕特里克和我的署名，并以相同方式共享。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。